DIFFERENT APPROACH.
AS CNN'S NICK WATT REPORTS,
THEY'RE MAKING HOMELESSNESS A
CRIME.
>> TENNESSEE JUST BECAME THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
BRAND THIS A FELONY.
PITCHING A TENT ON PUBLIC LAND
THAT'S NOT ACTUALLY A CAMP SITE.
>> WE'RE OUT HERE HOMELESS,
TRYING TO STRUGGLE TO MAKE IT
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT
WORSE ON ALL OF US BY
CRIMINALIZING IT.
>> IT'S A HUGE DEAL BECAUSE A
FELONY OFFENSE CARRIES UP TO SIX
YEARS OF JAIL AND THE LOSS OF
VOTING RIGHTS.
>> AND MAKES FINDING A JOB OR A
HOME EVEN HARDER.
>> THANK YOU, MR. SPEAKER.
>> THE BILL'S SPONSOR DECLINED
OUR OFFER OF AN INTERVIEW BUT
SAID THIS.
>> THIS BILL REQUIRES LAW
ENFORCEMENT GIVE A DOCUMENTED
WARNING FOR THE FIRST INCIDENT
AND ANY PUNISHT THEREAFTER IS UP
TO THE PROSECUTORIAL DISCRETION
OF THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
>> TUNISIA GREEN SAYS POLICE
HAVE ALREADY TOLD HER SHE MUST
NOW OBEY THAT SIGN.
>> THEY SAID THAT IT WILL BE AN
ACTION THAT WE'LL GO TO JAIL.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANYPLACE ELSE TO
GO?
>> I DON'T.
I HAVE BEEN HERE A YEAR.
>> NEXT DOOR IN MISSOURI, A
SIMILAR LAW TAKES EFFECT THIS
MONTH.
A MISDEMEANOR NOT A FELONY, BUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT DON'T
ENFORCE THE CAMPING BAND CAN BE
PUNISHED, AND MONEY EARMARKED TO
BUILD PERMANENT HOUSING MUST
INSTEAD BE USED TO FUND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS AND BUILD
STATE SANCTIONED TEMPORARY
HOMELESS CAMPS.
>> THIS IS A PUSH TO PUT THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE INTO
INTERNMENT CAMPS.
>> SIMILAR BILLS ARE NOW BEING
CONSIDERED IN ARIZONA AND
GEORGIA.
>> WE'RE SITTING RIGHT ON THE
TIPPING POINT RIGHT NOW.
>> IN OKLAHOMA AND WISCONSIN,
SIMILAR BILLS WERE INTRODUCED
BUT FAILED, AND THOSE
SIMILARITIES ARE NO COINCIDENCE.
THEY'RE ALL BASED ON A MODEL
BILL PRODUCED BY THE CICERO
INSTITUTE.
A THINK TANK IN AUSTIN FUNDED BY
A TECH BILLIONAIRE.
TEXAS PASSED A VERSION OF THIS
BILL LAST YEAR.
>> WE HAVE NO INFLUENCE EXCEPT
THE POWER OF PERSUASION.
WE'RE SAYING, HERE SEEMS TO BE A
BETTER IDEA.
>> SOMETHING CALLED HOUSING
FIRST HAS BECOME THE PRIMARY
APPROACH TO TACKLING
HOMELESSNESS, GET SOMEONE AN
ACTUAL HOME, NOT A SHELTER BED.
OFFER BUT DON'T MANDATE
ADDICTION TREATMENT.
AND THE REST SHOULD FOLLOW.
MANY STUDIES SUPPORT THE
APPROACH.
CICERO DOES NOT.
>> WE DON'T HAVE DECADES TO WAIT
TO BUILD UP BRAND-NEW HOUSES FOR
ANY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
WE NEED TO HAVE A SOLUTION
THAT'S ACTING RIGHT NOW.
>> HE'S ADDRESSED LAWMAKERS IN
TENNESSEE.
>> HOMELESS ENCAMPMENTS ARE BAD
FOR THE HOMELESS THEMSELVES.
>> AND IN GEORGIA.
>> YOU HAVE TO MOVE.
YOU NEED BOTH THE STICK AND THE
CARROT.
>> IN A LEAFY NASHVILLE
SUBURB --
>> I CAN SEE YOUR ISSUE.
>> YEAH.
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING YET.
>> THIS IS WHAT BECKY LOWE'S
LOCAL PARK NOW LOOKS LIKE.
>> NOTHING HAS BEEN WORKING.
NOTHING HAS WORKED.
>> SHE NOW SUPPORTS THE STICK
APPROACH, THE THREAT OF A FELONY
CONVICTION FOR JUST CAMPING.
>> WHERE DO YOU THINK THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD GO?
>> WELL, WE HAVE DOZENS OF
SHELTERS THROUGHOUT NASHVILLE.
>> I WAS IN A TEMPORARY SHELTER
AND I DIDN'T LIKE IT.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT TREATED AS
A HUMAN BEING.
>> A SENTIMENT SHARED BY MANY.
HOWARD ALLEN NOW HAS A PERMANENT
HOME.
>> WHEN I MOVED INTO MY HOUSE
AND THEY PUT THAT KEY IN MY
HAND, I CRIED.
THEN I CRIED AGAIN, BECAUSE MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS HAVE EARNED
THE SAME THING I HAVE, HOUSING.
AND WE CAN DO IT.
>> MAYBE WE CAN DO IT, BUT WE
SEEM TO BE INCREASINGLY
DISAGREEING OVER HOW WE CAN DO
IT, HOW MUCH CARROT, HOW MUCH
STICK.
EVEN HERE IN LIBERAL LEANING LOS
ANGELES, JUST A COUPLE HOURS
AGO, AFTER LET'S SAY A VERY
LIVELY PUBLIC COMMENT SECTION,
THE L.A. CITY COUNCI